what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some amazing news some
that some fans might be a little
confused about but mostly really excited
about now at the end of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 after all of the
post-credit scenes were done after the
end of the credits it said like some
Marvel movies do the legendary Star-Lord
will return and it looks like that text
was actually very very accurate stating
not just Star-Lord will return but the
legendary Star-Lord will return as it
turns out this seems to be very
intentional as James Gunn has recently
opened up in a recent commentary for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 about
Chris Pratt's Star-Lord slash Peter
Quill getting his own solo film not
another Guardians of the Galaxy film but
indeed a solo film for Star-Lord
possibly titled the legendary Star-Lord
as James Gunn mentions by name in this
commentary not only did James Gunn
confirm that Star-Lord is not done yet
this of course was also confirmed after
the post-credit when it said he would
return but he also talked a little bit
about what this solo film could be about
he even talked a little bit about the
plot and the way he speaks about it
makes it seem like it's a confirmed
thing like this is already in the works
over at Marvel Studios Star-Lord is
getting a solo film and it could be
coming sooner than we actually think
however there are a lot of questions
that come with James Gunn's announcement
teaser here like could James Gunn
possibly be directing this film even
though he is over at DC now and when
exactly will this movie come will it
come in the Multiverse Saga will
Star-Lord have a pretty significant role
to play in the Multiverse Saga or will
it come after in Phase 7 or Beyond we'll
break all that down but first let's go
over exactly what James Gunn said in
this commentary like I mentioned it's
commentary featured on the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 digital release where
James gun talks about Star-Lord
returning and this is what he has to say
in the commentary oh but not quite over
we always want to give somebody a little
something special and Chris and I
forever I've talked about how great it
would be to be able to do a legendary
Star-Lord movie a story with Star-Lord
on Earth trying to adapt to the
environment on Earth in the same way
that somebody else might try to adapt to
the alien environment of outer space
he's a fish out of water and just kind
of regular water so I can't wait to see
it now what's really interesting about
this commentary is that very last
sentence that James Gunn said he said so
I can't wait to see it seemingly
confirming this is going to happen this
isn't just something that they talked
about and hoped it would happen someday
it seems like something that is already
confirmed James Gunn stating that he
can't wait to see it because it's
happening he even talked to us a little
bit about the plot that they set up
Star-Lord adapting to Earth to normal
life which would be kind of big for him
because Earth compared to other places
that he's been to isn't exactly as
evolved especially with technology and
Earth unlike other places that he's been
only really has humans and of course
scroll right now but not that they
really know that so for the most part it
just has humans whereas other places
he's been to has a bunch of different
alien races a lot of other species out
there have figured out how to travel
throughout the Galaxy pretty quickly
just like how the Guardians use hex
portals so Star-Lord adapting to human
life could take quite a bit from him but
at the same time since he was abducted
when he was just a little kid he could
perhaps find a lot of Happiness by going
back to Earth and as we saw at the end
of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 that's
exactly what they set up Star-Lord went
back to Earth he went back and he found
his grandfather the post-credits scene
even showed us the two of them having
breakfast at a table where there was a
newspaper that talked about Kevin Bacon
being inducted which is a direct
reference to the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special so it's all there it's
already set up Star-Lord is on Earth he
told the Guardians that he was taking
time off or maybe even never returning
again and he's going to essentially
figure out his life so he is on earth
now the only question is is James Gunn
going to write and direct this film
because the way he talks about it makes
it seem like yes he is however James
Gunn is now the co-ceo of DC Studios he
is in charge of the entire new DC
Universe and not to mention all of the
elseworld films as well like Batman and
the Penguin series coming so needless to
say he has his hands full and not to
mention a lot of DC fans and some Marvel
fans didn't like the fact that James
Gunn was still directing and writing
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and doing
promotions for it as he became the new
co-ceo of DC Studios however it doesn't
seem like James Gunn really cares about
backlash that often in fact most of the
time he's the one calling people out on
the the internet for sane and doing
really stupid things and he says that
him and Chris Pratt have forever talked
about how great it would be to do a
legendary Star-Lord movie and since he
said him and Chris have forever talked
about it that is him talking about him
and Chris Pratt doing the movie together
him writing and directing it with Chris
Pratt of course playing Star-Lord and
possibly helping with the scripting as
well so his talk is talking of him being
a part of it however going back to his
last sentence so I can't wait to see it
kind of does imply that he might not be
involved what he says here is kind of
like I can't wait to see what they do
with it not I can't wait to work on it I
can't wait to write it I can't wait to
direct it that's really not what he's
saying here he's kind of saying hey they
set up this movie to happen he did his
part in Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 he
got Star-Lord back to Earth he did the
ending credits where it said the
legendary Star-Lord will return he
played his part and now he's excited to
see it for himself when Marvel Studios
does it himself so if I had to guess
just because of everything that is going
on with James Gunn over at DC right now
he's not going to write or direct this
film I would love for him to do it but
he does have his hands tied right now he
is very very busy he is trying to save
slash create a whole entire other
superhero Universe which is very
understandable but clearly Chris Pratt
is game clearly they have already talked
about Chris Pratt returning as Star-Lord
that's why they said the legendary
Star-Lord would return now he thought he
was just going to show up in another
Avengers film which I'm sure he is going
to do I'm sure he's going to be a part
of the King Dynasty or at least Avengers
Secret Wars now when will the actual
solo film come I'm gonna be guessing
that it's going to come in Phase 7 or
Beyond based off of everything that
we've heard so far about Phase 5 and
phase six there doesn't really seem like
there's any room for a solo Star-Lord
film plus not to mention this film seems
kind of like a starting over a new
beginning type of film and that's really
not going to be able to happen until
phase seven as well when the MCU
essentially is going to kind of have a
restart as well I'm not saying the MCU
is going to be resetting but after the
events of Secret Wars people are going
to be recovering universes are going to
be recovering and it's going to be a new
chapter so that's a perfect time for
Star-Lord to kind of have a new chapter
as well plus not to mention he did kind
of have Celestial Powers we're still a
little unclear about that at this point
in time because ego called himself a
Celestial however he of course does not
look like the other celestials who have
been introduced in the eternals but when
Star-Lord asked if he was a god ego did
say small g-sun so maybe he wasn't quite
on the level as the other celestials
that we saw in the eternals but perhaps
Star-Lord could play an interesting role
in the story of the eternals and the
celestials clearly the celestials are
going to be coming back at some point in
time as well as the eternals and if
Star-Lord hears that name celestials
obviously he's going to remember that
his father was a Celestial and that he
himself has Celestial blood inside of
him even though his powers were
seemingly removed I'm gonna bet that
they come back at some point in time so
that could definitely play a role in
star-lord's new movie that is going to
be coming as well and like I said the
movie seems like it's pretty much locked
in especially with that final sentence
by James Gunn so I can't wait to see it
if him and Chris Pratt have been talking
about this since the first Guardians of
the Galaxy film that means they have
definitely talked about it with Kevin
feige and this sounds like a project
that Kevin feige would love to
Greenlight so it sounds like this movie
is indeed going to be coming at some
point in time so go ahead and tell us
down below what you would love to see
from a solo Star-Lord movie and give us
your best guess on what you think this
movie could be about also don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 so Marvel
Legends items or some DC items we pick
one winner at the end of each month and
the winner gets to pick one item if you
want to support the channel even further
you can check us out on patreon you can
visit our website and our Discord server
that will link down below and you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf